to house Gomez - Pierre de ba and
welcome to prop hunt yeah
Kamath can Wow if I was a prop I would
totally fallen over by now what am can
you gotta give us a hint where are you
[ __ ] laughs what happened
vicen you're not dead nothing's amazing
that's a superpower
absolu this makes money you know yeah
and the other one GZ stand up this is
awesome I walked into a back what what
happened well haha I don't know what he
yell like that he must be one of these I
was by these boxes is he one of the
boxes I don't know terrifying
oh that was so not fair I was so excited
oh where are you [ __ ] I'm gonna see you
boo
I'm grossed out I gonna push every
single bar all over until you [ __ ] up
there oh yes yes
aren't you sanika
I can't catch ready gosh
but you did you get arrow signs or okay
okay
you're just like a taming I get it whoa
something assassination oh damn I took a
lot damage why is his car so low I do it
I do it what gave it away
ken wait ken Ken Ken wait what why'd you
keep shooting the chair I shall as well
Peter Darren
wait how'd you move objects like that II
like there's one two minutes makes my
mind high fine
oh yes so it's us now yeah yeah Bigfoot
don't hide without me okay that's not no
that's I think that's a good idea
got it yeah what time do we hop cuz I
don't see a countdown timer anymore I
can make you have two seconds here come
here okay okay hey Ken
we call this yeah they were totally a
glass bottle don't flip them over okay
see ya oh I can wait stop waiting for
anything that is ieaving you can jump
okay no more Jim go go they were
beautiful [ __ ] on the ground which one
of you is it mink some movie subtle oh
can you get the [ __ ] out of it
wait I just walked up the stairs and I
was like oh
like I just woke up the third a skinny
was just it's just like a pure black
figure I was that okay then this is this
you booty wait a minute
why don't you know if you made me job
god damn it
oh we didn't what is this little thing
wise choice out in the corridor then
dead okay like a nice he can see me to
the wall
okay I am a box he's hiding behind
something or inside something I have
inside that box mood were you that thing
I was shooting on know who series I shot
like so many times I did it go outside
and close the door
why [ __ ] is that yay got him
Wade you got him no I thought I thought
I suppose the hole out here you can
flick squeeze into you I was wrong why
do I door open
why did that door open wait hi why are
the ghosts in here yo what time one more
show get Zurg I pres have you enjoyed
this episode of prop hunt we're having a
ton of fun playing it's I'm glad you
bros one more maybe like if you do hit
subscribe to become a birthday I'll see
you minute stay awesome breath
ah the mouse the mouse come here you
[ __ ] milk come a hippie
don't you know everything from me